[Music]
if you thought Shakira's Hips Don't Lie
just wait until you listen to her new
song because it seems as though her
lyrics also don't lie in her brand new
Spanish track titled bzrp music session
number 53 Shakira teams up with
Argentine DJ Beez a rap and seemingly
Shades her ex-husband former Spanish
soccer player Gerard CK whom she shares
two children with
okay so Shakira goes all in on her and
Gerard's messy divorce even noting her
ongoing tax fraud trial and apparently
implying PK was either responsible or
that he left her during these troubling
times adding the lyrics you thought you
hurt me but you made me stronger women
don't cry anymore they cash in
but Shakira didn't just throw shade at
her ex she also appears to share her
thoughts on her ex-husband's new 22 year
old girlfriend Clara
chiamardios
though if he had any hope that these two
former lovers might rekindle I'd say do
not hold your breath on this one because
Shakira sings it I wish you good luck
with my supposed replacement I'm too
good for you and that's why you're with
someone just like you